Welcome back to human emotion.
Um,
this is our final segment on emotion and evolution.
Again,
trying to conclude our thoughts today and discussion of his evolution all there
is to emotion.
Um,
and today we're going to be thinking about the evolution of emotion by actually
considering some criticisms to this theory and alternative perspectives.
Um,
so from the last two lectures we talked about the evolutionary theory of
emotion.
And the three basic takeaway points that we discussed were the fact that first
of all,
emotions are biologically rooted.
They are part of our evolutionary history.
Emotions are universal across cultures and emotion serves specific functions
important for our survival.
But really is this the entire story about emotion or should we be questioning if
emotion really is all there is to emotion?
Um,
are there any arguments against this perspective?
And if there are,
what might they look like?
So here,
this is what we're going to consider today or some of these counter arguments
and criticisms to evolutionary theory.
And our roadmap will go as follows.
So we'll talk about some of these criticisms.
We'll talk about one of the alternative perspectives,
which is called social constructivism.
And then we'll wrap up with our takeaway questions and expert interview of the
day.
So let's start here with some criticisms that have been given to evolutionary
theory as it applies to emotion.
So there's political,
conceptual,
and empirical criticisms,
and we'll talk about each of these three right now.
So political criticisms of evolutionary theory,
um,
suggest that this theory really seems to imply this really uncomfortable
biological determinism that everything about our emotions can simply be
explained by our sort of innate biological wiring.
Um,
gives very little influence or opportunity for things like culture or experience
to shift or change how we feel and who we feel these things about.
It also seems to largely emphasize sex differences as part of this biological
determinism that men and women are simply built differently and have different
emotional profiles.
And some would argue on these political criticisms that it can be interpreted as
justifying a darker side of human emotions.
Um,
that the reason we feel things like hate and rage are simply because we're wired
to be this way.
I'm giving very little room for four change,
um,
outside of this biological determinism.
So this is a sort of political approach to criticizing evolutionary theory.
The second is more conceptual.
So this conceptual criticism would argue that well the mind is not massively
modular,
doesn't have these programs or systems built in it,
like the ones that uh,
cause meetings and to be talked about.
Um,
or as a in the census scribed by these evolutionary psychologists.
in fact and said the mine was evolved to give us flexibility.
So it shouldn't just be the case that when we see a snake,
we just had this program that gets flipped on.
We should have an ability to be more versatile and flexible and how we feel when
we see things in the environment around us.
The conceptual criticisms would also argue that the ea but we talked about
earlier,
is not the sole environment.
If human adaptation,
this sort of Savannah Hunter Gatherer Society can't explain all of our current
emotional states.
Um,
instead,
as you can see here,
natural selection can only work in a very few generations.
And this seems to cast doubts on the idea that we stopped evolving thousands of
years ago.
Rather it there would suggest what we should still be evolving,
but not all of our emotions can be traced back to one simple environment.
The EA and some empirical criticisms,
uh,
suggest here that some of the findings behind evolutionary theory,
um,
that had been used to bolster these accounts of human psychology actually have
some major limitations in the studies themselves.
And because of these limitations,
they have other plausible alternative explanations as well.
And so empirical criticisms of evolutionary theory say that they just provide
these just so stories that we have fear just so we could,
you know,
flee from Predators or um,
we have certain facial configurations just so we could do this or that.
And in other words,
that these just,
so stories are really told after the fact in this post hoc fashion and that many
theories of evolutionary theory as such,
since we're telling stories of things that happened thousands of years ago,
our unfalsifiable,
we can't really design experimental studies that could readily,
uh,
show that these theories are false.
So when we think about some of these limitations,
I'll start with an example of some of the empirical criticisms.
So again,
here it's suggested some of the major findings that evolutionary psychologists
use to support their theory of emotion,
um,
may not be all that,
that they may actually have some serious fundamental limitations.
So the example I'll use as you can see here,
you might remember we just talked about was Paul Ekman study in New Guinea.
So here you remember,
he found that the preindustrial preindustrial tribe of the foray,
people were able to recognize facial expressions of emotion.
They are able to use words,
uh,
of emotion to match certain facial expressions and photos.
And after hearing stories or vignettes told they could pick out different photos
of people showing emotion expressions to match the story and write.
So based on this evidence,
um,
Paul Ekman concluded that expressions of emotion are basic or biological
universal to all humans across all cultures.
So in other words,
this story was seen as providing strong,
uh,
support in favor of this more,
evolutionary approach to emotions.
Um,
but is evidence really correct or are there some criticisms and limitations of
one of the founding,
uh,
studies behind the evolutionary theory of emotion with respect to this idea of
emotions being cultural,
universal or sort of biologically sort of innate or hardwired.
So let's see what the criticisms are right here.
So some of the criticisms of this New Guinea study of Paul Ekman are as follows.
So the first is that there's language differences and for example,
so you could saw that some of the emotions,
uh,
that would be used to match the stories were translated to the lake local
language.
But there may actually be some difficulties,
especially when it comes to emotion,
to translating them in ways that are identical or parallel across cultures.
Different cultures have simply different ways of thinking about or construing
the way they speak about emotions.
So there were translation problems.
Second,
and here's the issue,
is that they were provided with emotion words.
So you remember seeing a photo of an individual with an expression and six
emotion words.
So they were provided with the emotion words and they had to pick one of the
six.
So this is also thought about is the forced choice method.
So rather than me being given,
shown a photo and letting them tell the person what emotion that photo was
expressing,
they only had a limited option of choices to pick from.
So this may have increased the likelihood that they would pick the coat correct
or right answer.
Um,
so this forced choice method where they are provided the emotional words is seen
as one of the major limitations or criticisms people at generated about the new
Guinea study.
Finally,
as you saw in some of the photos that we showed as examples of the kinds of
stimuli that might have been used in that study was that they were almost these
caricature like expressions.
So many of us probably don't show these exaggerated fear responses or you know,
overly like intense smiles on our face in everyday life.
So are these photos actually naturalistic?
Do they really show the kinds of emotions that people across cultures are likely
to see in their everyday life?
And then finally,
this was a really unfamiliar task for these people in New Guinea.
One,
they were shown photographs,
which is not part of their everyday life in a preindustrial society.
And the people in the photos were white.
So they were not the kinds of people that they normally interacted with in their
everyday life.
But these were Westernized Caucasian adults.
So these are some of the criticisms or limitations of this study,
which is part of the sort of more general empirical criticism of evolutionary
theory alongside conceptual and political criticisms as well.
And as we talked about,
these criticisms of evolutionary theory have led people to think of them as just
part of a broader trend of these.
Just so stories.
Um,
so this was named after a Kipling's book.
Uh,
just so stories,
um,
and you can read this code here,
Doctor Mesmer's guide to bad psychology where he says evolutionary psychologists
provide us with these just so stories to explain everything about human behavior
and all without the troublesome need to assemble proof.
We can run fast because our ancestors had to escape cave bears got smart because
they had to know where the cave bears were and got sexy because they could
rescue cave babes from the cave bears.
So the idea is that we're just making up these convenience stories to explain
why we are,
you know,
fast,
smart,
and as he would say,
sexy without any sort of scientific or empirical proof that this is the case.
So where do we go from here?
How do we balance the strengths of evolutionary theories to emotion with some of
the criticisms discussed today,
political,
conceptual,
empirical.
And I think this is really one of the challenges we have here,
sort of taking the strengths with the weaknesses.
And I think one of the things here is to not get caught up any of the politics
and yourself as a student to really think about where does the evidence lineup
and what right now is the most sort of a compelling argument for or against
evolutionary theory.
So I would suggest that you not get caught up on being on one side or the other,
but simply have an open and receptive mind to seeing where the evidence may take
you.
Um,
but all the while for any theory that we discuss in class,
whether it's evolutionary or we'll talk about social constructivism later,
any kind of theory,
just to question it,
to question its basis because we know that the field of emotion about these
everyday and mysterious experiences,
we all know feeling angry or sad or happy,
um,
that this is a very new field and as many,
uh,
discoveries as well.
Sharon,
this course,
there's a lot of questions and always room to reconsider things.
So simply think about everything you read,
everything I tell you with a critical and open mind.
So we're going to now turn to social constructivism and I hope you take the same
mindset of bouncing strengths and weaknesses to this idea as well.
So Social Constructivism,
as you can see here,
was really sort of talked about a lot and one of the pioneers was James Avril.
He said,
emotions are not just remnants of our phylogenetic or evolutionary past,
nor can they be explained in strictly physiological terms.
Rather they are social constructions and they can be fully understood only on a
social level of analysis.
So social constructivism is this predominant perspective and anthropology,
sociology,
and even some philosophical traditions.
And this perspective really argues that emotions are cultural products that oh,
they're meaning to learn social rules.
So for example,
gender and social group differences in the expression and experience of emotions
are no accident at all.
But indeed they reveal the way that emotions are constructed within a certain
culture to serve particular social purposes.
Um,
Avril,
you can see here actually went to this more strongly state that emotions don't
need to have any biological or physiological changes.
Sort of the opposite of what we talked about with William James and his
physiological approach that we can actually have an emotion without a racing
heart whatsoever.
He would argue.
So he would say biology plays no role in emotions.
It's all about social norms and cultural constructions that have created and
shaped the emotions we feel today.
So if we think about social constructivism here,
we lined it up against evolutionary theory which says emotions are biologically
rooted part of our history.
They serve specific functions and their universal across cultures.
If we put this right up against social constructivism or what's also been called
cultural relativism,
we see a very different perspective.
We see a perspective thing that emotions are actually constructed by cultural
values,
by societal institutions and by differences in our language,
the way we think about and talk about feelings.
Um,
and that this is a strong claim.
They would say at the very extreme point that biology,
both our brain and our sort of autonomic nervous system played no role in
emotions at all.
And that there are these,
what they talk about is open systems,
right?
So that emotions are not fixed.
There's not one set of behaviors and physiological responses that you know,
sort of go with fear or that makeup sadness,
but that there are these open systems that you can construct an emotion in many
different ways.
You can have an emotion of sadness that has very different kinds of expressions,
are very different kinds of physiology that we kind of make up and put the
pieces together of emotions ourselves through social norms,
through learning,
through speaking with others as we grow up in different societies.
So as you can see here,
these are radically different perspectives and a social constructivists and
evolutionary theorists don't really seem to see things a the same way.
But let's think about what social constructivism is and what might be some of
the examples that would make them think that maybe biology plays no role.
And that culture really seems to play a predominant role in emotions.
So if we take the example of anger,
so evolutionary theorists would say that anger is considered one of the six
basic kind of evolutionarily evolved the motions.
But if it is,
it should be cross cultural,
uh,
in terms of being universal,
right?
But yet we don't see it across all cultures.
For example,
in the Inuit culture,
um,
we don't see anger because in this culture it would be too risky to experience
or express anger in the small homogeneous culture living in harsh communities.
Um,
and so because of that cultural context,
we don't really see the experience of anger.
So then can it really be thought to be sort of biologically basic are
evolutionarily evolved?
They would say no.
Here's one example how even one of the core basic emotions may not be actually
so basic.
The social constructivist also bring up the example of culture specific emotions
where there's actually some emotions that are not only not universal across
cultures,
but that we only see in certain cultural contexts.
So consider the emotion of uh,
my in Japan.
So umyes this interesting emotion that is described as the feeling of dependency
upon another person.
Um,
now this is something that's highly devalued in Western society,
um,
to have this indulgent feeling of dependency akin to what a child feels to its
mother,
but in more sort of,
um,
interdependent are collectivistic societies.
Like in Japan,
this is a highly valued,
highly what they call hyper cognizant emotion,
that scene rather predominantly.
So what's interesting is why would there be some emotions and some cultures and
not emotions and other cultures if emotions are really thought to be these
hardwired biological systems that originated early in our history and should be
across all cultures.
Okay.
So that's sort of an introduction of social constructivism and what we're gonna
do today is rapid with some takeaway questions and then discuss social
constructivism and more depth with our expert interview today.
So let's move to our takeaway questions.
So for today,
they,
the first one is what are the main criticisms of an evolutionary approach to
emotion?
What were the empirical criticisms that we discussed today against Paul Ekman is
a new Guinea study.
And then finally sort of what are the three central tenets or critical core
pieces of the social constructivist account.
And can you provide a couple examples of evidence in favor of this alternative
approach to understanding emotion?
Turning to our expert interview today as part of the experts in emotion
interview series,
we will be talking with Dr Yulia Chance Sova Dutton,
who will share her experience on whether emotions indeed are socially
constructed.
Dr. Chen Sova Dutton received her phd from Stanford University and is currently
an assistant professor at Georgetown.
Her Research Interests Center on cultural shaping of emotions and social support
and she conducts exciting work on emotion and culture internationally and East
Asian,
uh,
Russian and west African cultural contexts.
Um,
interestingly,
she's also a native of Russia,
so I now turn to a very special experts and emotion interview with a treasured
colleague of mine,
Dr Yuliya,
Yulia,
and Sova Dutton.
Okay,
thanks for a great class.